this honors for the world-renowned
groundbreaking physicist Stephen Hawking
Hawking died in March at the age of 76
he was laid to rest Friday and
remembered for his earthly and even
interplanetary contributions Roxana
Saberi reports from London for a
scientist who called himself an atheist
a memorial service at Britain's
Westminster Abbey must have seemed
ironic in this holy place where God has
been worshipped for over a thousand
years but tributes paid by luminaries
like British astronomer Martin Rees were
a reminder that for decades Stephen
Hawking helped people look beyond
earthly matters to the mysteries of the
universe nobody else since Einstein has
done more to deepen our understanding of
space time and gravity Hawking was born
in Oxford England in 1942 as a 21 year
old PhD student he was diagnosed with
Lou Gehrig's disease a debilitating
condition he was told that would take
his life in just a year or two he beat
the daunting diagnosis by more than half
a century confined to a wheelchair in
using a computer synthesized voice
Hawking inspired the world with his
ability to soar beyond his disability
2007 he came close to flying in space
himself from NASA's Kennedy Space Center
he took a zero gravity flight and moved
freely for the first time in 40 years
space here I come
and we now commits his mortal remains to
the ground earth to earth ashes to ashes
on Friday Hawking's ashes were buried
between the remains of two other Giants
of science Isaac Newton and Charles
Darwin as he was laid to rest the
European Space Agency beamed his voice
from a satellite dish in Spain toward
the nearest known black hole more than
three thousand light-years away we are
all time travelers into the future he
said let's work together to make the
future a place we want to visit for CBS
this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
London well between Newton and Darwin
that's such an extraordinary figure and
it really helped us to stay inspired and
have this sense of wonder about the
everyday everyday